alright it looks like we are now live
I'm gonna give this a few minutes for
people to start catching up logging in
and writing questions so it looks like I
already got one person writing welcome
so nice today and this month actually
the the philosophy pop up I thought
would look kind of complicated topic one
that's I think very important and one
that the Stoics and Cicero had a lot to
say about - you know Giants in modern
moral philosophy Jeremy Bentham father
of utilitarianism Immanuel Kant you know
one of the heavy hitters of day ontology
and then some of the ethics of care
stuff would have to talk about and that
is the relationship between justice
understood and whatever since we want to
construe it and what we could call
beneficence or kindness or generosity
something that is usually construed is
going beyond justice so what I think
I'll do is I'll talk in the first part
of this a bit about that and a bit about
the event that we've got coming up here
in Milwaukee as well don't let me forget
about that and then I'll just start
fielding questions hopefully most of
them will be on on point and has
something to do with the topic I'll take
a few that that that don't if there's
time for that so this idea about about
justice and benevolence or justice and
kindness why you know why would they be
in conflict with each other well I think
one one way that people look at justice
is that you know it can be reduced to a
set of rules or decision procedures it
shouldn't involve our feelings or our
effects it should be you know more or
less impersonal and it should apply to
everybody equally across the board and
then we've got this entire realm of you
know it's not necessarily personal
as such although a lot of benevolence
and kindness and generosity is displayed
in personal ways in in relationships but
it could also be through charity work it
could be you know what goes above and
and sometimes people want to talk about
two kinds of duties right they talk
about strict duties and less strict
duties or some duties being super araga
Tory that would be the less strict
duties and the idea is that so we've got
a set of duties that that have to do
with justice the way that we ought to
treat everybody and some of it could be
involved in personal roles and
relationships since I am a professor I
have to treat students in a certain way
since I am a father I have to treat
children in a certain way and so on and
so forth right and then there's this
this entire you know realm of extra
stuff that makes life good that that we
need so you know you don't want to say
necessarily that the personal
relationships that we have should be
matters of justice they could be
something instead going beyond justice
right and so let me start by talking
about the Stoics the Stoics thought that
you could make that distinction but
actually treating other people well and
you know say saving their life in some
cases you know offering them water when
they're thirsty I mean you actually
might think about the the various you
know acts of mercy that the Christianity
talks about early on and you would find
Stoics doing the same thing and seeing
that as falling under justice because
they had an expanded conception of
justice Cicero talks about this in on
duties which is coming from Panaji is's
discussions and Cicero says justice
actually has two sides there's you know
what we can call justice in the strict
sense and that's what we named the
virtue after this social virtue and then
there's benevolence or beneficence or
goodness to others benignity us right
benevolence iya benefits benefit gen sia
and love even fits in there as well so
for the Stoics it wasn't quite so simple
as just drawing a dividing line between
these these are all part of the virtue
of justice a person who's actually
cultivated that virtue or trying to work
in accordance with it would in fact be
helping their fellow human being and it
could extend as far as all of humanity
the Stoics for Cosmopolitan's in that
sense so let me actually talk before I
jump into talking about other people as
well
about an event that we have coming up
here locally I'm very excited about this
we're actually going to be getting some
some interesting press about this
locally and the the you know news and
and radio and things like that
so we have found it and when I say we I
mean myself and II Chaka and Crake and
air have founded a chapter of Sofia
which is the Society of philosophers in
America and it's a it's an organization
that's that's devoted to trying to do
philosophy in a public way sort of like
what I'm doing here right you guys are
all over the world we're gonna talk
about an important set of topics there's
no you know presumption that anybody's
read the texts we're having kind of an
open discussion although it's not as
open as it could be because you know I'm
on the viewer the the the end of the
camera and I've got the microphone here
and you guys write me but what we do
here with Sophia is we have local
community conversations and Milwaukee is
a place where I think talking about the
relationship between justice and and
kindness is pretty important you know I
think a lot of people you know associate
Milwaukee mostly with the founds and
Happy Days but this is this is a major
metropolitan area that is growing very
rapidly still has a lot of problems with
inequality and access but is in many
respects a pretty wonderful place to
live and work you know not for everybody
and that that's a problem but but in in
general a really exciting place to be
and so you know these issues are very
important to get not just philosophers
talking about I mean Marquette is over
there UWM is that way and they do some
outreach but it's much more important to
get everybody else discussing these
issues and so that's what Sophia is
doing so we started a chapter st.
Patrick's Day here I'm putting that way
because that way is west just about four
or five blocks from here at the downtown
library we're gonna be hosting this
first discussion and then we have the
vents plan for August and November as
well the August event is to help
teachers incorporate philosophy into
their curricula and high school teachers
and the November event will be for world
philosophy day so that that's enough
about that let me come back to this
issue of justice and and benevolence so
you know Cicero actually gives us some
guidelines for it you know one of the
worries is well if we go beyond justice
just what we know we actually owe to
other people or you know bonds of
fidelity or things like that aren't we
gonna be like at the mercy of everybody
how do you know who to give to how much
do you give of your resources your time
your your effort are you on the hook for
like helping all of humanity or if you
don't are you a bad person these are
these are live issues back in in ancient
times just as they are today and Cicero
laid out some some interesting
guidelines he said you know you should
try to help as many people as possible
but don't exhaust your own resources
doing so because you also matter you
also are somebody who has to look out
for themselves he also says that we
should proportion and this is where say
the stoic viewpoint would differ
considerably from you know some other
viewpoints he says you should proportion
the the you know benevolence to the
merit of the person so somebody who's
really you know quite a good person but
really down on their luck because of the
way fortune has treated them
they he thinks have a greater demand
greater you know merit then somebody who
is chronically dependent on others
because they just you know don't want to
get their life together so there are
some some guidelines for this for the
Stoics you know when we look ahead to
like you know the really probably the
two most important figures I would say
in modern moral philosophy Jeremy
Bentham and Immanuel Kant and and I when
I say most important I don't mean that's
my assess but I mean that's that's
probably you know sort of the industry
assessment right I think there's many
other people who are quite important as
well but you know Bentham and you know
mill after him in the utilitarian
tradition and Kant they're both going to
treat these issues as well
kontin will actually write you know if
you've read the groundwork to the
metaphysics of morals the metaphysics of
morals actually includes metaphysical
elements of Justice which which is about
you know how we organize society Bentham
was was looking to try to reform both
British society and and and society
worldwide along utilitarian lines that
means that to try to produce you know
better sets of outcomes in on the whole
for for human beings and and he thought
of it in terms of pain and pleasure but
there there are other forms of
utilitarianism that think about it in in
other ways and you know Bentham thought
that many of the the ways in which
society was being organized and many of
the decisions that people were making at
the time were actually misguided from
utilitarian perspective and he thinks
that that Duty is you know our our
duties are what are going to improve the
general happiness so there may be some
cases where we're called upon to go
beyond the laws and to volunteer or to
help the stranger in need he also
doesn't think that it should be
completely you know willy-nilly we we
should we should think about these
things when when we're doing them you
know
because we we do have only so many
resources so they probably should go as
with the Stoics to some of the people
who are either more deserving or where
it's going to lead to a better increase
in outcomes and you know you can see
this more recently with the notion of
effective altruism saying that it's very
easy for us to give to people in our own
society who we see firsthand though one
of my dogs is having a kicking storm
right now alongside he's a 13 years old
and kind of fading fast so he goes into
these Jags every so often
anyway Bentham you know he would Bentham
would say this and you know Peter Singer
has said this recently as well that you
know perhaps aiding people in the third
world we get more bang for our buck in
terms of what we put into it and it you
know it could be through micro lending
it could be through volunteering it
could be through giving money to to
charities although you know we've seen
that that there's often you know a lot
of wastage going on with that so we
would have to take that into account as
well can't you know is is coming at
things from a different perspective he's
less concerned about our happiness
although he is concerned about human
happiness and he thinks that we actually
do have a moral duty to benefit others
he thinks that we don't have a moral
duty to benefit ourselves we we do have
kind of a duty to keep ourselves from
being miserable so that we won't be
terrible to everybody else and but he
does think that we we do have a duty to
benefit other people and he thinks this
can be universalized
and it's also a way to those of you who
know Kant's ideas to treat other people
as as ends and if you think about you
know now we're getting into things about
well how do we give and and this is
something where the Stoics where the
utilitarian is where conscience would
all be very concerned about you know are
we being controlling paternalistic when
we give to people are we treating them
as equals who are
that you know hard up or are we treating
them as if they're simply children who
can't manage their lives or you know if
we do it in a bureaucratic way are we
are we treating people you know in ways
that are sometimes if not entirely
dehumanizing certainly not respectful of
their humanity
the other the other thing I wanted to
mention was the ethics of care which is
a more recent moral theory although I
think you can see you know currents of
it going back a long ways all the way
back to you know some some ancient
philosophy as well it really got its
perfrom from feminists getting into
ethics but I don't think that it it has
to be confined to that that sort of
origin and the ethics of care it's sort
of an umbrella term and and it
encompasses a number of different you
know moral perspectives but but we can
say this it says that you know a person
is not just an isolated individual they
are who they are through their
relationships and we should value
relationships we should also place an
emphasis as we're doing our moral
reasoning on certain affective states
like empathy or compassion they you know
I don't see that is absolutely
revolutionary the way some some
theorists do but in relation to a lot of
modern moral theory it is emphasizing
something that often does get left out
if you think about contour you think
about you know most ways in which people
construe utilitarianism if they don't
actually read Bentham who who has a lot
to say about feelings but if you if you
you know look at that sort of stuff I
think the the ethics of care thing is
right that there is sort of a justice
perspective and then a care perspective
and the better theorists say well we
want to bring these together we don't
want to just contrast them against each
other and say boo justice all care or
something like that
we we want to
you know find ways to reconcile them
with each other which is difficult to do
and I think that the ethics of care
people and some people in the literature
have done this I think that they would
be really helped by looking not just
backwards to say Hume and his
discussions of you know sympathy or or
Adam Smith but looking backwards to
Aristotle I mean Aristotle said a lot of
boneheaded things about women but just
ignore those for the time being and
think about it or looking at what the
Stoics have to say or looking at what
some of the early Christian writers have
to say or Plato and the whole Platonic
tradition effect was not always left out
and and personal relationships and
benevolence within those you know were
important in in ancient theory so I
think that you know we bring these these
perspectives together
you know I'm an eclectic I tend to I'm
not a very doctrinaire person I think we
have to draw in multiple traditions let
me take a look at some of the things
people have been writing and let's see
what people have to say I'm gonna skip
the question about the philosophical
significance of the occult because it's
not really germane here if we have time
I could come back to it if you so here's
a good one from William if you define
kindness is willing the good of the
other and a type of platonic Aquinas
sense would and justice and kindness be
united I mean ideally yes but we can
make a distinction between them and
people do make a distinction between
them right you can do what is just
without willing the good of the other
you can just be a great rule follower
you know and be all about social order
but not really care much about your
neighbors I think I think there is there
is a distinction to be observed there
and we shouldn't try to just conflate
everything together that doesn't help
anything making good distinctions is an
important part of you know our activity
as philosophers James asks is there such
a thing as objective morality or
injustice yeah there's all sorts of
morality Zand and justice I mean this is
this is one of those things where we get
into very meta ethical discussion that
that we don't have a lot of time for
here but there's different approaches to
this you could do it in a comparative
way and look at well what do most people
actually mean when they say justice
you'll find a discussion of this for
example you know in Cicero in Aristotle
in John Stuart Mill and they all look
fairly similar to each other objective
you know I mean what is the contrast
they're too subjective there's nothing
wrong with being subjective we are
subjects after all right we do have we
do have first-person perspectives on
things the question is whether something
becomes wholly subjective or or not I
think that's where we get into problems
Magoo writes love the idea of chapters
dedicated to that oh you mean local
chapters I was thinking for a second
about books I was trying to figure out
what I'd said that could give rise to
that yeah
local chapters there's a couple I'm
going to do a digression here at this
point so there's a couple large
organizations that I am involved with
that have local chapters that I think
are a really good thing to do so one of
them is Sophia and I think that's that's
that's great I I love their their their
idea I love their their mission I've
been doing it for years and years so
it's sort of a natural fit for me I
think it's an important aspect of our
common life that often gets left out how
philosophy real philosophy not just sort
of like academics talking to other
academics but stuff that can you know be
used by working professionals by
lifelong learners by ordinary people I
think that's incredibly valuable the
other organization that I belong to that
we have a local chapter of here in
Milwaukee I think some of you may
already
know about is the stoic fellowship my my
wife and II and I help to organize that
that or that that local chapter but it's
taking on a life of its own and we hope
eventually to pass on leadership to
somebody else
and have them do it and then I can just
show up and and you know not have to be
on point for for meetings but I think
that's that's a great thing and the snow
the larger stoic fellowship very helpful
very supportive I'd like to see stuff
like that for other philosophical
traditions as well and I'd be happy to
participate in them and Milwaukee is a
wonderful place for doing this this sort
of thing I'll say as well all right
Francis asks what is the relationship
between justice and peace that's a good
question
somebody who's particularly good at
discussing that is is augustine he
brings it up over and over again you
know if you think about what what piece
is right I think a lot of people think
of peace as a mere cessation of
hostilities and genuine peace has to go
beyond that it has to involve what the
the medievals would call a cone cone
cone at concordia there we go
Valon taxes right a harmony or Concord
or at least getting along of will see if
you and I basically just are at arm's
length and distrust each other and you
know it really misinterpret each other's
motives and and have you know alternate
narratives of who the bad guy and who
the good guy is we don't really have
peace if we're not actually extending
each other the benefit of the doubt
and justice can provide justice in the
strict sense can provide a set of
guardrails for morality right but it
can't provide it at it in its entirety
you know I think for example about
Martin Luther King's you know famous
saying
you know the law cannot make a man love
me but it can at least make a man not
kill me and I'm not saying that
everybody has to love each other but you
know mutual respect of each other's
humanity I think that's what's required
for peace so this is why you know simply
having a peace treaty or you know some
restoration of social order does not
count as peace we don't live in a
peaceful society here in America is
incredibly factionalized and fractured
as our culture or politics are that's
not a state of peace the very
exploitative economic situation that you
know we live in also not a state of
peace and it would take a lot to to
actually work towards that and justice
is going to be at the center of that you
know I think a lot of times people have
had to swallow all sorts of did justices
and you know they get pretty angry as a
result or despondent and and part of
what has to happen in order for things
to get better is bringing all that crap
to light and sorting through it and most
people don't want to do that you know
it's the same thing in personal
relationships too by the way you know if
you've got people who have a bad
relationship for a long time it's
probably going to be the case that
there's a lot of you know stories that
look very different from the different
sides and hearing each other's stories
without necessarily committing yourself
to them is is an important part of that
now you know justice there may be cases
where you know justice demands something
happen and then we can talk about you
know what what mercy or Misericordia or
or beneficence might might say and this
becomes you know very sticky in
situations where there's been a lot of
injustice committed on both sides so
sometimes you have to go beyond strict
justice in order to have have genuine
peace
let's see
Socrates Plato writes thought on Spinoza
and his ethics you know I read him every
so often he's somebody who I've taught
quite a bit not a fan of Spinoza don't
have to be people always get you know
worked up why not you know well I'm not
a fan of a lot of people I just don't
buy into the sort of pantheism and and
the you know the to attribute thing and
I find his stuff interesting just like I
find Hobbes interesting but I don't
think he has much to contribute here to
the conversation marksmen TM I missed
the intro what is the general purpose of
this speech so you know this is sort of
a general thing if you miss the intro
you can go to the video description you
can go to the Facebook event and you'll
you'll see like a descriptor so if that
comes up again in the future for anybody
it's very easy to find out we're talking
about the relationship between justice
and kindness or justice and benevolence
and how we could understand that and I
talked about Cicero and the Stoics
talked a bit about Kant bit about
Bentham a bit about the ethics of care
and you know I mean there's a lot a lot
of other theories we could have brought
in but I thought those would be a good
good starting points all right so JB and
here we go
JB and I both have things that are kind
of along the same lines same topic right
JB rights I know a lot of people on
disability and boy oh boy you want to
talk about dehumanizing and then tie
rights we should be careful of kindness
not being condescension or patronizing
we should enable people to get back on
their feet control over one's life feeds
into well-being yeah it's it's it's a
very that's a very tough thing and this
is this is where we get into some really
substantive discussions like what level
should helping people take take place at
and what you know how
a personal touch do we need on the one
hand it's tempting to you know try to do
it solely through
high-level governmental agencies because
then we've got you know first of all we
you've got taxes too if we can
appropriate them for those purposes and
we don't spend it just on military you
know craziness or or you know other
silly things and I'm not saying the
military is entirely Sileo that you guys
know I'm a vet but but some of the stuff
that that you see when you're in the
military really is quite wasteful and
could be spent on many good things but
there's there's a sort of like oK we've
got money there's also like doing things
on an economy of scale and I think
there's a common perception at least you
know among many that if we can have it
be run by the state it'll be more fair
things will be more balanced and it
rarely turns out like that because when
you get down to it you know we need
people who can actually engage on a
human level you know a great example of
this is I you know those of you who are
outside of this country one of the big
problems that we have for returning
veterans is that many of our VA Veterans
Administration hospitals are quite bad
but one we have here in Milwaukee very
good I know that in part because my
father-in-law uses their services my
half-sister worked for them for a long
time and and you know see knowing these
sorts of things on the ground is very
important but many of them are terrible
in how they dispense care and they treat
they treat people many of whom are are
disabled very poorly as if they're just
sort of forms to fill out or numbers and
so that that is a real a real problem
and now you know tie points out we
should be careful of kindness not being
condescension or patronizing that's
important as well
you know we do have to make distinctions
like you know a friend of mine who's now
doing his just finished up his theology
degree and
is is going to be doing working on a
philosophy PhD but who's been a drug
rehab counselor for years and years
really brilliant guy he you know he's
putting it out that you you you know
with time you develop a frenetic
capacity to tell like which junkies
really do need the patronizing treatment
and and which of them are at the point
where now they can start doing more for
themselves and where if you treat them
the same
you're gonna screw up that person more
you're gonna you're gonna you know
induce more sort of dependency and
bitterness and so this is a very
important set of considerations you know
how do we train people to do that it's
really difficult the all qui Ora 44
isn't compassionate stoic passion so
these they're we're getting in a bit of
technical term so passions for Stoics
are not a good thing right
the passione sort / - bad Sione's those
are excessive movements within the the
mind or the soul when it comes to
compassion well that depends on what we
mean by it if we mean by it the the
feeling of pity allows in Greek then yes
that's bad but Epictetus says you know
sometimes that's less bad so in his
discussion about anger
I think it's 122 right in the discourses
he says listen you'reyou're getting
angry at all these people and they're
doing what they're doing because they're
poor bastards who can't do anything
other than that until they like learn
something different so why the hell are
you getting angry at them if you're
gonna feel something feel pity feel
compassion allows towards them rather
than feeling anger or gay but you know
he also suggests a lot of things and so
does Marcus and so to Seneca that would
fit in with a different understanding of
compassion where we where we deus you
know sort of
sympathize with the person or empathize
with them and we try to alleviate their
suffering and we can imagine what it
would be like to be in their shoes
although we're not ourselves being you
know effectively you know brought into
those shoes and sharing exactly the same
feeling right so the Stoics depends on
how we how we view compassion they
certainly thought that we we need to
help people in need we need to try to
console those who are suffering but they
thought that we want to also make sure
that we don't get drawn into it so
difficult thing to do so let me ask what
do you think about rorty's views on
ethics I I haven't read Rorty since
graduate school so I don't really have
anything to say about that I wasn't
impressed with them then I I don't
imagine I'll ever spend the time to
reread R or D so you know because my
time is kind of kind of scarce Yoga asks
is kindness the willingness to do the
right thing for the purpose even if it's
not the optimal decision for yourself
also as kindness doing the right thing
for the person even if they don't think
so so those are two good questions
there's more I would say we don't want
to try to define kindness by the
willingness to do the right thing for
the purpose even if it's not the optimal
decision for yourself in part because
justice sometimes demands that courage
sometimes demands that I mean in a
certain sense like from a stoic
perspective or from a Content
perspective it is the best thing for
yourself
you know being virtuous is indeed as
good as it's going to get for you even
if it means you lose a little you know
some money or some time or possibly even
your life but I guess from a utilitarian
perspective you know you know if you're
giving money out right that's less candy
bars or coffee or I don't know whatever
else you're going to buy with it
now people buy all sorts of things that
give them pleasure early alleviate their
own pain and so the I think that could
be a part of what kindness involves but
you can often be kind without it
affecting you badly in any way you know
or it might you might actually think
upfront that it's going to be but you're
you're actually happy that you here's
here's like a good example right so one
of the things and I forget exactly where
I came across this boat but somebody
pointed out that one thing that homeless
people typically don't get in their day
is somebody actually remembering their
name and addressing them by their name
and it seems like a very trivial thing
but I can see how it would be quite
important and I can't say that I know
all all the homeless people around here
because I don't and and you know quite
frankly some of them are people who I
wouldn't want to get to know but I have
gotten to know a few and I try to
remember their names and use their names
when it when I'm talking with them and
you know I'm a busy guy so I'm always
you know thinking at first oh crap you
know this is gonna be like a long
conversation but then when I do it
afterwards I that it it was something
good for that person but also good for
me and that I didn't really lose out on
you know I can still get my stuff done
and it could have been you know I also
waste time doing other other things
during the day and so this really wasn't
a waste of time whereas some of the
other things that maybe now I won't be
doing really would be more of a waste of
really [ __ ] around on Twitter or
something like that right so so
sometimes you know your perspective
changes I I guess you could say right is
kind of doing the right thing for the
person even if they don't think so
sometimes it is
I mean raising children includes many
instances like that or dealing with my
old dogs you know you know they
sometimes they want to do things that
are beyond their capacity
I don't let him do it I'm being kind to
them and some you know my our old dog
there he tries to you know I'll kiss him
on the face and he'll he'll try to bite
me he doesn't try to bite anybody else
sort of like my grandpa when he had
Alzheimer's he used to take a swing at
my uncle Scott who was the best guy to
him you know uncle Scott was really
great with Grandpa but somehow grandpa
got fixated on that and Scott was always
continually you know taking care of him
nice to them and sometimes that's just
the way it goes
so yeah you you you may do stuff that
people themselves are saying this is not
kindness to me well they may not be in a
good position to judge that but there
there we get into the paternalism issue
as well
JB rights against empathy makes a very
interesting case for justice actually
being being impaired by caring in some
senses yeah I haven't taken a look at
that book I've read some blurbs about it
I suspect that you know there's probably
a lot of cases where where justice does
get impaired by by sort of a
misunderstood empathy let's call it
right but I think that in a person who
develops themselves the right way and
that takes a lot of work and I'm not I'm
not putting myself forth as an example
there they they inter fuse with each
other you know that's one thing that we
see over and over again we see that in
the Aristotelian tradition we see that
in the Stoics we see that in Christian
writers it's a continual theme swar the
Sun so how does one define kindness when
one does not know the motivate what the
motivations of one's action is how do we
draw the line between benevolence and
self-serving action disguised as such
well I assume you do know the motivation
for your own action and if you don't
then you know spend some time doing some
introspection or dialogue with people
and figure out what the motivation for
your action is I don't think that that
Conte is right in saying that you know
we we could never be sure that there
isn't some self-love at the bottom of it
I think he's he's you know being
overdramatic
saying that you know I know that there's
plenty of people who who lie to
themselves but that doesn't mean that
that we're all lying to ourselves right
and and it's also possible for you to
share both of those at the same time and
them to be sort of warring within your
breasts as you know the the people would
would say in the old epics write about
about different feelings but you know
that doesn't have to do with how you
define kindness you can define kindness
and in a variety of ways see what Cicero
has to say about it see what you know
Bentham has to say about benevolence if
you're looking for definitions I'm not
saying you have to like you know drink
the kool-aid you know I am now a
utilitarian or the Benthamite sort or
anything like that but we tried these
concepts on to see how they work so you
want to actually go out there and and
and get yourself a stock of them and
start start trying to apply them Oh
Linden has a great question here is it
possible to compel kindness or as
kindness need to be self generated if
we're understanding kindness as
involving sort of the effective
disposition no you can't really compel
it what you can do is you can compel the
behavior that goes along with it and you
can also like include a little mini
lecture about not being a jerk because
you know of whatever reason you're gonna
get and we have to do this with kids a
lot right and we have to do this with
adults who are who are kind of jerks as
well and I know from personal experience
because I've been on both sides of that
myself because I've been a jerk plenty
of times in my life but no I think
they're they're you know you're not
going to be able to get everybody to be
kind in every circumstance and it's very
difficult to be kind for many of us
myself included when when other
negative feelings are at play like you
know for me the worst is anger I would
say when I'm angry with somebody I find
it very difficult to be kind to them
even though I'm I'm inclined with people
who I'm close to to be kind to them but
there's something about being angry that
that makes it very difficult for other
people could be you know being sad you
know depression makes us less makes us
more self focused and unless other
focused fear you know many people may be
afraid to show kindness to others
because they may be taken advantage of
maybe they have been taken advantage of
many times that that's a difficult idea
env2 and me was that's that's a tough
one yeah all right let's go on para
Tosun in japan there is the idea of path
of my it's the behavior and opinion one
displays in public to foster ease of
relationships in the spirit of weekend
as alcohol plays well I don't think
alcohol plays a similar role because
alcohol tends to you know you drink
enough of it and your true feelings will
usually come out you know if you don't
like somebody and you've been making
nice with them and then you you know you
have a six-pack maybe you'll actually
tell them what you really think so I
don't think those are those are actually
connected in that case Reid asks have a
red Honda rents book on the trial of
Eichmann yes and I actually mentioned it
in my talk on on a rant last year you
can find the video for I'm actually a
big fan of a rent I like her quite a lot
even when I disagree with her I find
what she has to say quite interesting
and worth worth checking out I'm gonna
be doing a talk on her locally here for
a senior group which I will not be
filming at their request but she's yeah
she's somebody who I like quite a bit
Lynden has another question what do you
think if any is an argument for a role
in emotion and moral reasoning in action
rather than opposing emotion well
there's a couple good arguments to be
made one and so here I will bring in
Spinoza right
although Spinoza is not saying anything
that Anselm isn't saying or quite a few
other people aren't saying as well and
that is that you you can't simply oppose
an emotion with reason you need to
oppose an effect with another effect so
if you want to you know try to keep your
anger from screwing things up then maybe
you do you know you bring in the love
that you feel for the person or or
sadness that you know what's happening
to the relationship or something like
that and you change you're in effect
changing the affective focus and this
may require a good bit of you know
discipline and exercise of the will may
involve even doing some bodily things
quite quite an interesting idea there I
mean the other thing to say too is that
you know in classic virtue ethics
whether we're talking about you know
platonic Aristotelian stoic to some
extent epicurean you know that you want
to be a well integrated person and you
want to have integrated the affective
side of yourself with the rational side
and the affective side should help to
sort of guide you the right way it's
it's like what you know Aristotle talks
about in terms of you know so he talks
about the prior ASIS the the core of who
you are you're sort of locus of choices
and things like that as being on the one
hand mind and few
with with effectivity noose or Eck decay
or as being you know effect or desire
infused with with with intellect or
reasoning or access the anoetic a title
of my my blog right or XS do you know n
TK that's why I chose that so I think
that that's another thing that you can
say and then you might also say that you
know certain emotional states are and
that Aristotle says ooh so we can go all
the way up to ethics of care with this
are something like signs of good
character or are needed for moral
reasoning in the proper sense by the way
the people who bring up you know Humes
you know reason could only be the slave
of the passions that's what he was
actually driving it with that you should
have the right passions so that you can
reason properly he never stopped
reasoning all right but you want to have
have the passions involved in ethics so
I think those are you know three
different standpoints we could use for
thinking about emotion and moral
reasoning Francis writes what is the
difference between highly theoretical
abstract treatments of philosophical
topics and more practical considerations
how is one more useful than the other I
think that question you basically
answered it and asking it how are
practical considerations more useful
than highly theoretical abstract
treatments you know that's that's I
think pretty pretty straightforward
right the the real thing is well how do
we get from the one to the other and you
know this is something I've been putting
a lot of thought into myself because
it's something that I do fairly
naturally I think in part because I've
always been practically oriented when it
comes to studying philosophy but also
because I have to work with so many
clients who want to use insights from
philosophy to help them out and that's
that's sort of what I bring to the table
so a lot of that requires first you you
actually do have to understand the
concept to some degree you don't have to
understand it perfectly but you have to
understand the concept
you're working with and then you start
you know looking at examples and case
studies and you know sort of journaling
and honing your own observation about
that that sort of thing and and it helps
I think to have an interlocutor somebody
like a coach or trainer or a good friend
a confidant to work on that sort of
stuff with there's a great question and
I may not have a good answer for it from
me s mice and ten I guess
best books you've recently read actually
all the stuff up there stuff I've read
many times so I can't I can't say about
that recently read have I read anything
new recently that really impressed me I
haven't you know I haven't read anything
that new that that that really impressed
me oh but it but I'm not being asked
about new right so best books I've
recently reread let's say you know I I
do this worlds of speculative fiction
series and last month it was Fritz
Leber's libraries how it's supposed to
be pronounced but I'm gonna say Lieber
anyway the Pfeiffer and the grey Mouser
stuff the swords against or swords you
know all set in Loch Mar man is he an
amazing writer
he's craftsman like I was just talking
about this actually with a client my
tooth who also really loves loves his
work and we were both talking about what
it would a great writer he is so that's
that I've been rereading Heinlein
actually for that the one that I've been
rereading most recently as the moon is a
harsh mistress great stuff really
enjoying that too and what else have we
got up here you know I've been working
with another client working through this
role ethics of epictetus I've read this
before it's pretty good I like it I
disagree that out a few points
[Music]
what else oh yeah you know another
client I'm working on a big fan of
Gabrielle Marcel tough to read for some
people because he kind of circles around
ideas over and over again but I actually
really enjoy his stuff I'm gonna do some
writing on him if I find the time before
too long on his concept of mystery and
how it fits in with you know what how we
should understand technology ken right
so would true justice necessarily
involve a degree of mutual trusts would
it involve it I think it would help to
produce it definitely would it involve
it insofar as you can expect justice
from the other person I guess so right
and Cicero stresses and I think he's
right about this that an integral part
of justice because justice is complex
Aristotle you know really great at
demonstrating this we don't always mean
the same thing when we use a single word
justice but there's a lot of different
interconnected meanings Cicero says that
one key part of it is you know keeping
faith fulfilling promises you know being
honest with each other I think that that
sort of long lines of what you're
talking about and that that's pretty
important Katherine I'm working on the
social contract theory versus free will
I wonder in the history aspect for the
United States would fall under I don't
know how you oppose free will the social
contract social contract presumes beings
that can freely enter into a social
contract so I don't think they're
opposed to each other so you might have
a bit of a problem with that I mean the
u.s. you know I think the social
contract theory has been part of the way
we understand what's going on in in the
u.s. it's one of the reasons we have a
written constitution for one thing John
Locke actually played an important role
in in in a lot of early thinking about
this and he's a social contract theorist
but
does the social contract really describe
well how things work in terms of justice
in the United States I don't think so
ideological II yes we're like that
person violated the norms you know do
whatever we have to to them but that's
that's not really the way things work
when we get down to the mechanics of it
have here's a great one from Linden have
philosophers ever talked about how to
reach how to reach people who are
ostensibly unwilling or unand to engage
the argument debate exploration dialogue
dialectic yeah a lot of them have and
some of the some of them have the
conclusion that well there's nothing you
can do with those people yeah stay away
from them or if they're gonna pose a
problem well you might have to eliminate
them sister actually talks about this
again in on duties but there's a lot of
other a lot of other people
Chad what do you make of Steven Pinker's
character a characterization of
Nietzsche's philosophy is destructive
and responsible for Nazism communism
right-wing libertarianism well that's
dumb you know Nietzsche isn't
responsible for for those I mean you
know I guess is what we've got there
sort of an updated popper right although
you know was Nietzsche responsible for
communism he he actually you know is
anti-communist in his writings but no I
mean here's there's there's two things
to say one is that if you actually read
Nietzsche's writings
you cannot buy into those three isms
because Nietzsche himself is saying what
a dummy you are he Nietzsche hated
anti-semites which is at the core of of
Nazism hated communists hated the
Socialists and I think current
right-wing libertarianism Nietzsche
would look at those people and say wow
you or you are a bunch of like dud
conformists so so there's that right so
there's the conflicts with what
Nietzsche's actually saying and then you
can say well maybe Nietzsche was too
care
listen what he wrote and and it led to
those through misunderstandings and he
can say at what point is he responsible
for those misunderstandings you know is
Marx responsible for Mao I don't think
so
is Nietzsche responsible for pick
whoever else you like I don't I don't
think so
ask Rattus is there a clear difference
in the understanding of kindness between
those who assert that man is a social
being and those who do not I don't I
don't know that so when we talk about
human beings being social it's not a
question of whether we're social or not
it's a question of whether how close how
how important that is in our our core
and whether we are whether we should
understand ourselves as sort of having
the capacities that we do through being
involved in in society or whether we
should think of ourselves as isolated
individuals if we do think of ourselves
primarily as isolated individuals
kindness becomes something that's you
know purely supererogatory you can do it
or don't do it doesn't matter all right
totally up to you if you think about it
in terms of social beings then it
depends on how you conceive of that like
Aristotle includes generosity among the
virtues he also thinks that we're social
beings Rousseau you know very different
sort of view on human nature and
development thinks that sympathy is
quite important you know then we could
go on and on and on there's gonna be
different understandings of that I'd say
so
all right
Chah do you think that stoicism upholds
or defend strict social hierarchy or the
caste system nope it didn't in in
ancient times and it doesn't now and I
can see how some people say well you
know they're very passive about it well
then you want to read actual Stoics and
see what they say about cosmopolitanism
and about standing up against you know
tyranny or things like that and that
will solve that that issue for you I
think Jake Lloyd how does virtue ethics
relate to stoic ethics stoic ethics is
one one particular tradition in virtue
ethics virtue ethics encompasses a
number of different traditions I would
say that stoic ethics can be understood
as sort of a and this is the case for
many virtue ethics by the way and it's
sort of a mix between virtue ethics some
dant illogical aspects and some natural
law theory by the way natural law theory
in its classic form is very closely
connected with virtue ethics these are
these are not necessarily exclusive
categories the way that some people try
to make them in in textbooks and in
Twitter Wars and things like that
these are broad designation so stoicism
you know stoicism views the virtues as
absolutely central let's go down a
little bit Jude oh there's a good
question the ulquiorra in a stoah stoah
perspective how would you apply justice
and kindness to yourself well I mean you
need to stick up for yourself right well
that's another misunderstanding when it
comes to stoic so some people like well
you know the stoic will just say you
know whatever that person is doing over
there isn't really harming me because
it's not harming you know me unless I
choose to look view it that way or it's
not affecting my my pro races or stuff
like that
and
you know that works for the sage but
that doesn't work for everybody else so
there's there's cases where we should be
like okay that's enough [ __ ] on your
part I'm not putting up with that
anymore right because I am getting upset
and it's not a good thing for me to get
myself upset so I'm gonna you know have
to do something about this and then then
kindness towards ourselves I mean this
you know what they're talking about is
kindness or benevolence is really
exercised towards others but but you
know to be forgiving of ourselves
Epictetus you know talks about you know
the transformation from like blaming
others to blaming ourselves and says
that's not the ideal we want to be at
the point where we're not blaming
anybody not in the sense that we're not
scribing responsibility but we're not
like you know oh that person sucks you
know that that sort of thing so I guess
that that would that would fit in with
it as well let's see here William
thanks for the the Hegel videos you just
reached the force and understanding
section that's that's a difficult
section of the work probably one of the
most difficult sections of the work glad
that it's helping you out a F are you
familiar with Hayek's work at all yes
I'm familiar with it at all I'm not you
know anything like a specialist in Hayek
and I don't have that much time to do
that all right I'm gonna skip through
some stuff a bit so this is kind of
funny Bertrand writes for future pop ups
can you put no jordan peterson questions
in the title I haven't seen any Jordan
Peterson questions so I think here the
first mention of it so far so that's
actually pretty good
let's see AAF has another question have
you ever thought about starting a
podcast so if you go to my patreon page
you will see if you if you look through
the goals that I am committed to
starting a podcast actually I'm
committed to two different things once I
reach a sufficient level of support one
is taking my videos and turning them
into podcast
for people who want mp3s the other is
actually starting a bonafide podcast but
it has to get to the point where the
time and effort that I'm expending on it
is being you know supported by by
somebody because I you know I
occasionally gig by teaching for places
here locally or online and I don't have
so but that's that's a very small amount
of income you don't make much on YouTube
from advertising and I don't have you
know a government agency or school or
something like that supporting me so
everything that I do comes out of my
time so if you want to see that sort of
thing then you want to support on
patreon and get other people to support
and once it hits that that that level
you know I will start the podcast but
until then I it's not really that that
feasible for me so cha has got to follow
up some somebody I argued with said that
Stoicism to find goodness in reference
to an individual's place in the social
hierarchy so they said that for example
a slave could only ever be a good slave
what do you make of this but your
interlocutor doesn't know what the hell
they're talking about so it's a
non-starter because they they got
Stoicism wrong to begin with so there's
not much to say in response because you
know it's sort of like beginning with an
argument where the premises are all
wrong you're like well that's an unsound
argument case closed
try again right so I would I would just
go back to them and say let's read some
stoic text let's see what the Stoics
actually say about this or maybe ask
them where did where did you get your
idea of Stoicism from was it from
reading some secondary source or maybe a
blog post or something like that so yeah
one Matt dinger I think do you think
there's such a thing as human nature as
in a baseline for what
human is a lot to be in stoicism gives
tools and methods to achieve that state
so yeah I think there is a human nature
I don't think it's a baseline I think
it's actually a set of capacities that
require an awful lot to develop that we
can have some you know general things
that we say about it but it's more
complex than Aristotle thought it was or
the Stoics thought it was or and we need
to combine resources from you know moral
philosophy from certain you know
religious traditions trying but try to
secularize them to some degree from
psychotherapeutic concepts and from
other areas in order to form a much
better composite picture and even you
know other other theorists like you know
think about johann who is Inga's
discussion of play for human beings and
how how that is at the the essence of
human nature as well so human nature is
not something simple it's not a baseline
it's it's it's a set of capacities
oftentimes not never fully realized but
we are the you know the most the most
interesting and complex beings that
we've we've discovered so far by the way
I don't preclude saying that other
beings that are not biologically human
might not be human in that respect as
well or at least semi human and able to
partake in in you know what it is it's a
rationality involves the stoicism
provide us with tools for that yeah it
does
so does Aristotelian ISM so does so does
the Platonic tradition so do a lot of
things that's that's why I'm an eclectic
I would say that I draw you know very
heavily on the stoic tradition I drop
very heavily on the Aristotelian
tradition I also draw very heavily on
the existentialist
and then everything else is kind of a
smattering of different things but I use
that to make sense out of human nature
let's see an order hole can you tell us
a story about your bookcase yeah I can
tell you a story but what
we may be understanding can you tell me
a story a little bit differently so my
son who is now just gonna be 11 soon at
Christmastime I had him help me put up
several more bookcases and I also had he
had him helped me bring we originally
had the bookcases in in our spare
bedroom where that where the kids stay
when they're here with us and we decided
to move them all up into the master
bedroom and so he helped me with that
that project we had to get like a
shopping cart from down below people you
know use that to bring groceries in and
we just loaded it up with books I hooked
the the bookcases that were already put
together up myself they're all Billy
bookcases from Ikea and we you know we
did the work together and him helping me
put together the bookcase I was very
happy to do that because he doesn't get
a lot of that sort of thing at home
unfortunately and I don't know how he's
getting it at school so it's it's
important to have that kind of
father-son bonding stuff over over
things that's that's important for human
development right so there's a story I'm
gonna go a little bit long we're already
at five after but I'll go a bit long on
this moreover my thinking recently has
been clouded by deterministic thinking
because I find it logical what work do
you recommend to get me out of that
pothole if I had to pick one thing I
would say take William James's the what
is it called though I just had it in my
mind damn it
the will to believe I think it is it's
short essay good good little little work
and it touches on free will to some
degree and it also touches on the
consequences of our beliefs
if you think that determinism is right
you probably won't seek out much
to disconfirm that all right so you
could actually make an effort to seek
out something other than that and then
you can ask yourself did you make that
effort deterministically or from free
will I would also recommend like
Cicero's on fate but that's a difficult
work and it's fragmentary but but it's
good to take a look at it very short and
it's do a video and I should do a video
on that that's that's a good work the
all queer r44 what type of man do you
think Epictetus was back in the day if
he was alive today what would he be like
I'm sure very different than he is he
was back then
if he were alive today what kind of man
was he from from all accounts somebody
was very honorable very pragmatic and in
how he worked through stoicism one of
the things I like to say to people who
you know they want to study stoicism and
they read epictetus they're like I don't
buy this stuff and I'm like Epictetus
doesn't care if you buy this stuff you
know he's laying it out for you and he
would be perfect if you were around
today he would be perfectly fine with
saying hey you think you got something
better go try it out and then after it
completely blows up in your face then
maybe come back and we'll talk a bit
because he says stuff like that in his
class is like you know yet a student is
like you know I don't need stoic logic
you know I don't need to study all this
stuff I can just do stoic ethics you get
all these people doing that sort of
thing you know and calling themselves
you know modernizers and epictetus is
like oh okay
try that out see how that works and then
you know then they come back to him and
they're like well I got taken in by this
argument he's like well dummy you should
have studied the logic that oh now do
you want to now do you want to study it
I think that's that's sort of key to his
approach you know he's very no nonsense
he probably wouldn't get tenure if he
was a philosophy professor could have
student evaluations all over the map so
you know
mattias rain also does free will exist I
think it I think it does it's your
choice whether you want to believe that
it exists or not notice you're using
something like freedom of choice
I suppose to do that Francis asked if I
would go back to the first question
about philosophy and the occult I don't
know that there's much for me to say
about that what's the philosophical
significance of the occult as far as I
would say none but again I'm not an
expert on that sort of thing I don't
think I don't think that's important
myself so ask Radice have you studied
Islamic philosophy in any depth no I am
NOT and and would I create videos on it
probably not in part because I haven't
studied it in depth and I'm at a
disadvantage
you know with respect to Islamic
philosophy comparatively to other things
where I I don't read Arabic you know and
I'm not gonna at one time wanted to
learn Arabic I'm moving this thing
because the lighting is getting getting
bad there we go but I I'm not gonna have
time to learn Arabic I doubt I'll even
have time before I die to properly learn
Mandarin so yeah probably it's not gonna
get to that stuff unfortunately but
hopefully there will be other people who
do you know maybe we can get some some
grad students from the Marquette Aquinas
and the Arabs project too interested in
that sort of thing
Linden writes a blog who's in his book
Oh once all excited but I bought it too
quickly it arrived in Spanish well yeah
that's not particularly helpful let's
see oh
Linden's got a question what are your
favorite ancient Greek concepts which do
not have exact translations or
equivalents in modern Western thought of
the English language
sumos thu MOS right it's translated
anger passion spirit probably a whole
bunch of other things as well and it's
sometimes it does mean anger sometimes
it's actually a synonym like an
Aristotle for or gay which also means
anger but it means that part of that
part of us that gets riled up and is
associated with anger and courage like
in Plato and in certain parts Aristotle
but not other parts it gets other
technical meanings so it's very
difficult to translate one I'm actually
laughing at an ordered holds one way
that I'm gonna answer in a minute but
Juan writes how was your experience as a
philosophy undergrad I experienced
benign neglect my undergraduate teachers
were convinced that this is back in the
early 90s that that you know philosophy
had basically you know sort of brought
into dead ends there was an analytic
philosophy but it was kind of dying out
and then there was existentialism then
there's process philosophy that's all
they knew you know and they had us you
know study some things in the history of
philosophy but none of them were even
remotely interested in it
and so I just read a lot on my own and
studied on my own and thought about
things and unfortunately ran into a few
people who gave me fuller you know you
could say reading lists actually one guy
Yoshihiro Manoa gave me a whole bunch of
books there's a whole story I could tell
about that and I frankly I spent much of
my undergraduate years
partying and doing a bit of writing much
of which is embarrassing to look at at
this point and getting involved in
relationships and you know some of the
occasional fights and stuff like that so
it was kind of finding myself I am NOT a
good model for or how to do philosophy
studies when you look at my academic
years an ordered whole my new roommate
is doing his PhD in philosophy I tried
with him talking about science parts of
a whole he seemed disinterested I think
he's more and if we call what's a good
starting talk yeah I don't know if he's
really into Foucault I don't know you
could talk about some of who COEs ideas
or ask him to explain them Foucault
Tian's
sometimes can be a bit weird in some
respects and some of them are you know
very much drink the kool-aid kind of
people others are much more pragmatic
about using Foucault I will tell you
this that that you know contemporary
criminologists the ones who are serious
working in prisons they don't they don't
buy much of what Foucault is the same
discipline and punish they give very
much over-generalized about that but
that's not going to make friends with
with a guy I don't know is that's a
tough question
so Tecmo do you think kindness requires
sacrifice versus being kind on the
promise of heaven or if you're a highly
empathetic person are you actually doing
it so that you don't feel bad about the
other person's suffering I mean there
are people I suppose whose who are
induced to do good behavior by telling
them that they'll get to go to heaven as
a result I don't think that most people
who do good behavior that that's a great
way to consistently motivate them and I
think some people may say that as a line
but don't really mean it depending on
what society they're in and then the
well you know if you're if you're B if
you're highly empathetic are you
actually doing it so you don't feel bad
about other people's suffering that's a
possibility but it's not the only
possibility I mean you could also like
genuinely care about other people that's
why you're highly empathetic you know so
I can ask the question I can't answer
what is the best way to remember texts
that you read long term I don't know I
don't use memory techniques or anything
like that I just unfortunate and then
I've got a pretty good memory
so the all query I haven't tackled stoic
logic can you give me a brief synopsis
of it I cannot give a brief synopsis in
part because it's sort of scattered
across a bunch of texts and we have to
sort of reconstruct it we do know that
the Stoics made a lot of advances in
logic we don't have any treaty so stoic
logic as far as things go but you know
we we know that that there was certainly
a discipline about it Francis asked do
you agree with gzx statement that
philosophy went downhill after Hegel no
there's a lot of great philosophers so
alright looks like we have the last
question unless I'm mistaken what is my
opinion on the cynic philosophy is from
J crash 23 is there any way to channel
the diogenes mindset to the modern
capitalist system so I think that a lot
of people who portray themselves as
cynics here I'm in agree in agreement
with Lucian the the satirist in ancient
times are really full of it sorry I
think that that a lot of people love to
talk the cynic line Epictetus also talks
about this to love to talk the cynic
line but can't actually follow through
on it people who actually can are
amazing they're extremely rare and
that's really about all I have to say
about it you know I would say read you
know epictetus is very long chapter on
the cynic profession and see what he has
to say about that okay let's see last
question I think how can you tell if
you're suffering from a psychological
problem or a philosophical problem they
may not be mutually exclusive psychology
in fact came out of philosophy there's a
lot of cross influence between the two
you know I guess one way to do that is
go and see if somebody diagnoses you
here in the United States different
diagnostic manuals and other places like
France but see if somebody diagnoses you
using the latest DSM
with a disorder and then see if you
believe them and see if you think that
they're right about it I mean there
really is no way to draw this this
dividing line so so easily
uh let's see all right I'm going to take
this this last one and then I'm going to
call it a day
from Kebbell do you believe Hegel's work
was a uniquely christian project and how
much is lost changed if Hegel is right
outside a Christian perspective depends
on what you mean by Christian
perspective can you read Hegel without
being a Christian and understand what
he's saying
yeah can you understand what he's saying
about Christianity without being a
Christian yep can you imagine what you
know things would be like if Hegel's you
know viewpoint was realized sure so you
don't I mean it really depends
I mean Hegel himself was down on on say
Catholics does that mean Catholics can't
read Hegel no as a matter of fact there
was an entire school of theology the
tubing in school devoted to try not you
know read you know fuse you know
Catholic thinkers together with with
Holly and thought I mean of course you
can read Hegel's work outside of a
Christian perspective I mean I don't
know anybody who uses Hegel who who
claims to be a Christian and finds Hegel
has anything to do with their devotional
life or or anything remotely like that
and Hegel himself you know there's a
great saying I'll sort of end with this
some you know Hegel maintained that he
was an Orthodox Lutheran and somebody in
English Stanley rose and in his his
commentary on Hegel said if Hegel indeed
was a Christian he was in a church of
one meaning he's the only member of that
that particular church so all right I'm
gonna say one more thing before I go
actually I'll say two more things before
I go up no I'll say three first of all
thanks for all the great questions
I enjoy these these these these chats
and stuff like that so that's that's
point number one point number two if
you're in the Milwaukee area st.
Patrick's Day right here downtown at the
Central Library the Sophia chapter
inaugural meeting we're gonna be talking
about these issues of justice and
benevolence it's a two-hour thing the
first hour you don't have to have read
anything just a general discussion being
facilitated by Andy cray and myself
second is more intensive thing you
should have read Cicero's on Duty's book
one for that and I will be leading
people through some of the key ideas of
that text and answering questions
it's co-sponsored by the stoic
fellowship of Milwaukee as well
third thing I'll say thanks to all of my
patreon supporters they're the ones who
in effect make it possible for me to do
this by their financial support and if
you want to become a patreon supporter
you can go to patreon.com/scishow and so
if you don't you know you can thank me
but you should also thank my patreon
supporters because they're the ones who
in effect underwrite there's this sort
of thing and you know we have a lot a
lot of fun doing this so we'll do this
again a little bit later in the month on
Facebook live and got a few other events
coming up so hope I'll see some of you
there and glad to see all the familiar
faces